ليله اخرى بدون كهرباء
تحتفظ كارينا ببعض البنزين لتشغيل المولد
الكهربائي
محظوظه جدا لانني اشتريت هذا المولد منذ
عامين الان تضاعف سعره 3 مرات
كل ما تبقى لها من بنزين للحصول على ساعه
واحده من الكهرباء من اجل مشاهده كلمه
رئيس
الاوكرانيس الامريكي
[تصفيق]
روشه
انهم يشاهدون رئيسا لا يهزم لم يرغب ابدا
في مغادره بلاده منذ بدء الحرب لقد شاهد
رجلا واثقا من نفسه يحارب من اجلنا من اجل
اوكرانيا
عاد الظلام الى المنزل
الى الشموع
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي بات لا يطاق لم
نعد قادرين على توقع ما يمكن ان يصدر من
بوتن او الجنود الروسي بدون كهرباء لا
يوجد اي شيء من اجل استعمال مضخه الماء
لابد من كهرباء
والمدفئه تعمل بالكهرباء ايضا لا يمكن عمل
اي شيء
ترفض كارينا ووالدتها اظهار ضعفهما
بتاع الحاله اصعب نحن متفائلون وصامدون
لدينا اشعاع في داخلنا يجعلنا نتحمل هذه
الازمه
طالت وتحولت الى ماساه عقد الحياه
الاوكرانيه لكن مع هذا يحتفظون بابتسامتهم
ويامننا في ان يعود اليهما الامن
والاستقرار مره اخرى